bonsoir bonsoir oui oui nico bonsoir
j'ai appris trois quatre mots comme ça
ira ou n'ira ni crainte shaoliang
mireille hincker vous êtes aussi vous
êtes très beau oui je vais des gâteaux
je ne suis pas tout à fait démontré
comment je m'appelle lee décrivez vous
physiquement aussi belle que trois coups
et très bien quelle est la raison de
votre appel on écoute illégale
c'était dingue est directrice pour les
américaines s'appelle bénite date ni de
copines mais thierry garder comme on
applaudira c'est comme ça qu'on apprend
on de voir beaucoup plus jeune alors
voilà je vous racontais l'histoire on a
récemment vu arriver en france
les romancière chinoise on connaissait
pas romancière chinoise donc il ya mian
mian qui a écrit les bonbons chinois ai
weiwei qui a écrit shanghai baby voilà
alors on est loin de l'épousé soumise
aux pieds bandés et même de la
révolutionnaire en costume mao
d'ailleurs dans les années 50 je savais
pas du temps du maoïsme triomphant les
chinoises avaient droit seulement à une
demi-heure de sexe par semaine avec
monsieur cela suffisait par exemple
cela suffisait pour mes parents et voilà
pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui
voilà parce que ça lui suffit pas
shanghai ça ressemble un peu à hong kong
lors maintenant étrange non
parce que si on peut la considérer comme
une soeur de rencontre et d'ailleurs
pendant les années 30 c'était une perle
de de lorient et shanghai a été comparé
à paris shanghai sur le nombre des
grands magasins mais mcdo des cybercafés
donc vous faut le savoir c'est sûr c'est
pas du tout comment on commande imagine
c'est une espèce de mégapoles
maintenant il ya vu des voitures de vie
nocturne terrible hein il ya des
beaucoup de musique de drogue et de la
techno à shanghai
et alors les romancières chinoises ont
cristallisé un petit peu cette cette
révolution alors votre bouquin shanghai
baby voilà je le montre à la caméra fait
commencer oui oui
c'est bien à le sait bien alors ça sort
sous 3 couverture donc je rencontre
plein encore voilà gens montrent une
autre comme ça les gens montrent encore
une autre voie là
trois couvertures alors c'est un bouquin
que c'est vendu quand même en chine à
500000 exemplaires et qui a été pilonnée
ce que ça fait un scandale là bas quoi
trois couvertures
pourquoi qu'elle leur appli jo excuse
moi qui fait penser à rien c'est du fils
de didier interview vérité bien alors
donc on va parler de vous maintenant
très sérieusement après ce préambule sur
la chine et romancière chinoise
vous avez 28 ans vous êtes issu d'un
milieu aisé fille de professeurs
d'université et vous même vous êtes
diplômé de littérature la prestigieuse
université de fudan à shanghai alors le
premier scandale que vous avez fait en
chine si l'on est sorti le premier
bouquin qui s'appelait les cris perçants
du papillon vous avez fait un happening
vous exposiez 7 steve blanc où il y
avait une nouvelle écrite sur les slips
et votre photo comme signature c'est
vrai c'est ça voyez tout à fait oui ça
fait un scandale
oui depuis ce moment d'alléger d'achat
noir c'est un chauffeur deux mois tandis
que les femmes chinoises je pense
qu'elles sont contentes de ce que j'ai
dis parce que je sers en quelque sorte
alors porte parole
voilà punition de virginie despentes
chinoise ou est ce que je veux dire à
bien moi j'essaie de ne pas lire les
sous titres en même temps bien alors ce
bouquin à shanghai
baby donc c'est l'histoire de coco parce
qu'ils prennent les non-classés mode de
prendre d'élan coco comme coco chanel
elle a une copine qui s'appelle madonna
donc voilà ces modes la voilà à la
chanteuse
ouais
je sens qu à 25 ans elle vit à shanghai
et elle partage sa vie entre thiam tchad
est un jeune chinois qui est impuissant
il hérite qui dit il et il est jacking
dont quand on est jeune qui de façon on
est impuissant même si on n'est pas un
puissant donc sa septième chaque qu'il
aime beaucoup qu'il idolâtre épi marque
qui est un allemand et qui a un énorme
sexe de m pas de maître avec qui elle
baise c'est frénétiquement coco
l'héroïne c'est autobiographique c'est
plutôt une espèce de semi auto graphique
c'est pas si grand que ça m'a donc
effectivement le livre a été censurée ça
fait scandale parce qu'effectivement les
chinoises sont souvent ça arrive et
s'ils ne sont pas satisfaites et avec
une étrange et bat le connaissent un
plaisir peut-être un petit peu
supérieure enfin tout le monde le sait
vous dites vous même tout le monde le
sait là bas il faut pas le dire encore
mois l'écrire donc elle a un peu mis les
pieds dans le plat
la tradition chinoise on peut faire
certaines choses mais on ne peut pas en
parler
je pense que ça fait partie de nos
traditions orientales voilà donc se
taper des allemands avec un sexe énorme
c'est possible mais il faut pas le dire
et pas l'écrire voilà chez nous c'est le
comprennent alors page 323 alors cet
allemand l'a fait fantasmer parce
qu'elle voit alors le mec il est marié
qu'une écolo qui s'occupe de la
protection de l'environnement il n'a
rien d'un asile allemand 1 mais elle
fontanes quand même sur le côté un peu
bas à 323 les femmes aiment avoir dans
leur lit des fascistes dans les bottes
de cuir résonne à leurs oreilles ça fait
un peu trip cuir toit c'est un peu sm un
peu smtd cuir
il faudrait pas qu'on pense que chercher
les fascistes certes bon je pense que ce
sont leurs propres fantasmes je suis
certaine désir même faire l'amour avec
nos pairs déjà page 80 ça commence
j'imagine les yeux germanique bleus
cruel et féroce vous excite pas qu'il
est en costume nazi avec des bottes et
un monde qu un manteau de cuir
non ouais c'est ça et ça va cartonner en
allemagne le kart wii
ils ont pas eu la même chose que nous
avec eux et voilà exactement c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas vécu tout cela
nous dans les années 40 pour eux c'est
un peu plus loin reste alors oui voilà
alors c'est tellement donc comme je les
dis un organe impressionnant et alors
elle seule l'héroïne coco est à la salle
a fait crier de douleur fait pour ça que
en fait qu se trouve dans une situation
délicate
voilà entre le désir et la souffrance
alors que toutes les femmes cherchent à
les combiner ensemble
exactement donc elle elle continue
malgré la taille du sexe et la phrase
j'ouvre les yeux avec un mélange de
haine et d'amour dans le regard assez
chaud un très très chaud mal à la marche
i sciences le plein de trucs qui
marchent bien
non qu'il ya des siennes gerima moment
et téléphone goûter enfin pas vous mais
l'héroïne de coco au téléphone à tianjin
donc le pauvre qui jack donc il est
impuissant et demain et pendant ce temps
marc lech son sexe à travers sa petite
culotte
voilà on y arrive jusqu'à l'esprit
qu'est ce qu'il est c'est bien la
littérature chinoise d'aujourd'hui mais
là ça je voudrais savoir si les hommes
français
ça leur arrive de lécher leurs femmes
j'ai jamais fait l'amour personnel c'est
des trucs vers un jour y arriver à ça
mais non ça on n'a jamais fait à travers
la culotte c'est vrai que mon fils est
le bouquin c'est pour ça qu'elle a trois
exemplaires on pense bien bien bon pas à
la fin page 306 j'en resterai là parce
que sinon après ça c'est là la tension
oui je sais c'est pour sa marque marc
parent attendant vous savez ça bah parce
que ça ne peut pas durer une histoire
comme ça s'est appuyé sur une cane
humeur bien évidemment mais aussi le
bourg de chagrin un peu comme si j'étais
pas là oui bien sûr on a déjà fait des
émissions sur le bot et je vois alors
trône et de réactions les réactions en
chine
le lift pilonné donc détruit
complètement détruit et puis alors
poursuivi vous avez été poursuivi par
des fous qui voulait absolument venger
l'affront fait à l'honneur national
parce que bien évidemment les chinois
c'est à dire ça tu vas pas là bas rhin à
loreley obligé de rester là si je n'ai
pas la science a imputé aux je ne sais
pas encore mais j'ai entendu dire qu'il
ya aussi un écrivain
franco chinois qui s'appelle quotidien
qui est un grand écrivain
ils prient les paumes elle est
d'ailleurs j'ai obtenu un livre j'ai
trouvé un élément sélection il avait
traîné
il habite dans une tour en banlieue là
ça va lui faire ma seule firme a aidé à
voir votre book a fallu changer les
idées shanghai et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu